puis 22 ans des enfants placés sont
accueillis ici
la semaine dernière des gendarmes et des
fonctionnaires de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ont fait irruption et ont
emmené cinq des sept adolescents qui y
vivaient il voyait bien que les gamins
ils étaient tous tristes et pleurer non
il ya même le petit nicolas qui avait 13
ans il est parti se cacher dans la salle
télé et il m'a dit rania je veux pas
partir je sais pas où je vais allez vous
mettre en foyer
c'est une lettre anonyme dont jean
claude rossi pense connaître l'auteur
qui a déclenché cette opération une
lettre qui évoquait des maltraitances il
y avait eu un précédent avec déjà une
enquête en 2015 qui nous avait blanchi
le département de saône-et-loire très
clairement l'histoire de 2015 avec
l'entier de cailloux se sont il faut le
dire franchement j'ai dû utiliser il
avait pareil ce n'est tocsin c'était une
catastrophe puis sont venus tous les
adolescents plus être entendu par les
gendarmes
l'histoire c'est s'est effondré la
magistrate a même perdu le dossier
cette fois ci personne n'a été entendu
avant la descente des gendarmes
rania et adam deux jeunes majeurs qui
vivent ici on refusait de les suivre
et ils ne se font pas prier pour
expliquer pourquoi ça fait cinq ans que
je suis placé et je peux vous dire que
ici en trois mois ce qu'ils m'ont
apporté
c'est c'est vraiment personne n'a su
m'apporter ce qu'ils m'ont apporté
c'est un endroit magnifique jean claude
g can sont merveilleux sens super sympa
ils nous aident dans absolument tous nos
projets moi je fais j'ai fait une
formation de serrurier métallier g us et
ap et là il m'a boosté un peu on va dire
pour quelle façon une autre formation
encore là je vais entamer une formation
de soudeur un peu embarrassé une
responsable du conseil départemental qui
souhaite rester anonyme nous a dit à la
fois que cette opération était justifiée
par des soupçons graves mais que le
département n'aurait fait qu'embrouiller
le pas au procureur pour jean claude
rossi tout le monde a voulu se couvrir
mais il y a une réelle défiance de
l'aide sociale à l'enfance envers les
lieux comme le sien il faut que ça cesse
qu'il faut que les départements viennent
voir les lieux de vie il faut que les
départements prennent conscience du
travail qu'on fait est qu'elle ait de la
confiance réciproque tant qu'on est sur
cette suspicion s'est pas trop ce qu'ils
font alors que tout est ouvert et qui
peuvent venir quand ils veulent il y
aura en france
encore et encore des lieux de vie qui
vont fermer
intempestives et des dégâts
incommensurables sur des enfants qui
sont installés depuis des fois des
années rania et adam eux continuent à
vivre aux bruyères encore choqué par ce
qui s'est passé